join me now from Glasgow is the leader
of Scottish Labour Jim Murphy thank you
for being with us mr. Murphy's here in a
case you drive a well-known I'm he drove
up in bar heads and the sunshine and
Nicola Sturgeon says you're desperate
are you desperate know what we're doing
is reflecting the truth and the facts
what we publish today's advice here and
they said I see not of Labor Party
statistics and I'm not even of SNP
statistics these are independent
auditors economists that the ifs that
have been very clear that the SNP plans
for what they call full fiscal autonomy
I accept it's a mouthful kind of
impenetrable in a economic rifle but
what they call full fiscal autonomy
leads to seven point six billion pound
funding up and why this has become news
just till your viewers can catch up is
that the debate and Wednesday evening
that I had with Nicola Sturgeon and the
other Scottish party leaders Nicola
Sturgeon said her party would vote for
full fiscal autonomy next year in the
House of Commons that would be the
abolition of what's called the Barnett
formula and a seven point six billion
pony I asked you when you went public
spending and those aren't my figures and
they're not your figures these are the
figures how much they effort on the
other hand when you took over Scottish
Labour you said you weren't going to be
dictated to from London are you in favor
of greater fiscal autonomy economic
autonomy self-rule for Scotland well the
fact is of course the Scottish
Parliament is going to have more
taxpayers but we're not going to give up
on pooling and [ __ ] and resources
across the UK one of the things that's
great about and the way in which we
organize society the way in which we
organize our pension system in a welfare
system is it we pool and share resources
across the UK don't we what the SNP are
suggesting is that Scotland cuts itself
off from all of the other types reason
all of the other revenues that's why the
rest of the you now hang on when we
that's why that point six billion poem
that's why they're called the Scottish
National Party is there because they
believe in independence and autonomy and
all you're doing with this document is
simply rigging the terms on which that
separation would take place and it could
be that there could be a
and incidentally incidentally I said I'd
call it independence rather than
separation but you want to call it
separation that's your choice but look
this isn't about the referendum this
isn't about last year's debate isn't it
about last year's disagreement in
Scotland people on who voted yes and
people who voted no in last year's
referendum they both wanted change no
we've got a chance for having that
change come the general election we can
kick out David Cameron but the point of
today's doors here is to shine the light
of truth I'm on the SNP and I'll stand
back but it's the only six billion poll
but just to translate the item just to
translate this onto what it really means
yet if you have that cut across the
board here in Scotland for example in
pensions if it 18 pound a week cut and
Scottish state pension the UK pension
here in Scotland where do we with a
little bit in open and honest about that
well we're being open and honest you're
not addressing the principle of this
which as I understood you said you
wanted greater powers for Scotland at
Gordon Brown said he wanted Home Rule
and what you're now doing is saying well
the consequences of that will be
terrible
therefore the SNP a toggle it seems to
me that you're confused
nothing Adam you I know you're
accidentally confusing yourself by what
you're saying what we are saying that
the Labour Party saying there should be
more power for the Scottish Parliament
but we would never give up on the UK
state pension system and we will never
give up on the UK welfare state and we
would never give up on the Barnett
formula that shares money
the SNP are saying they will give up on
the Barnett formula if you give up on
the Barnett formula introduced this bill
fiscal autonomy idea yeah what it does
is cuts the Scotland out of the UK state
pension and this is about the SNP being
open it's the end of UK state pension
but what you then Scott you're the SNP
else here it's all scare mongering and
all that so I think it's nothing of the
sort the day job when we talked about
the oil price last year and look what
happened to the oil price very quickly
from the Vantage of the rest of the UK
you're saying the rest of the UK should
go on paying the extra to Scotland
well at the moment the fact that
Scotland pays about 400 pound more than
that as the UK in tax when you include
oil revenues although those have went
down but we get twelve hundred pound
more back in public spending here in
Scotland
that's the Barnett formula that's the
way it works lever will protect that
we're not going to sell Scot the note
the SNP would bend the Barnett boiler
and take Scotland out of the UK pension
system that's utterly unacceptable